our guest today has acted and hit films
such as sunshine cleaning crank high
voltage Capote traffic Star Trek in the
upcoming highly awaited boondock saints
two along with this weekend's release
the film Mike judges extract for more on
on our desks you can visit clifton
collins jr calm let's welcome to the
film curse to do mr. clifton collins jr
hello hello hey how you guys doing this
morning where's morning alright how are
you quitting pretty sweet there
we go are we gonna go look at this party
start exactly Clifton what we're very
excited to have you here with this this
morning can can you start off can you
tell us a little bit about your
background like where you grew up yeah I
i was born in santa monica grew up
mostly in culver city mm-hmm spend a lot
of time with my grandfather and my
grandmother so that's a with leila high
school i'm a la native one of the few
one of the few router one of the few
fourth-generation entertainer grandpa
got me tap dance when i was seven and my
grandfather coincidentally started
entertaining the age of seven so that
was like 1932 he was a he'd perform in
the same tent that he was born and he
was a part of of these these four tents
in Texas called the Licata box which was
like a mobile of vaudeville tin so it
was like 'hey you build this tent you
create this show and you do publicity
and then when the show is over you pack
it up and go over there were nine
brothers and sisters and they did a and
they perform so and then my
great-grandmother performed for Pancho
Villa you know I got pictures of that
kind of stuff so we go we go deep we go
on in the family my sister now who
actually casts fray pro Webster and it's
done several JJ Abrams stuff like alias
and lost ok she and my cousin's work got
into jazz while me and my cousin got
into tab in 307 yeah so they got a son
they got us doing creative my
grandfather adamant about having us have
both a creative education
like artistic dancing musical
instruments and also an academic
education cuz my grandfather couldn't
read it's back then they really didn't
care about that kind of stuff you just
needed to make money for the UM the
family hmm yeah so they're from Texas
and I'm from Los Angeles okay and why do
you love acting why don't I love acting
you know it's so fun to put on other
people's shoes I mean how many times
have you like thought you watch me like
damn I wish I could do that or you hear
a great story on the news or you know
some heroic thing or some ugly thing or
you know you watch a vampire film like
the NY I'd led to be a vampire they got
their turn to a bat and go bite some
fine on the neck you know it's
like you know I mean it's like it's fine
man it's pretend and you know you go out
and do these things and you don't go to
jail or none of this stuff anything you
get accolades and get accolades to be a
bad guy uh-huh or a good guy you know if
you want to do it just and also the
research elements to our I really enjoy
getting into these roles so much so that
uh um it oftentimes affects my personal
life but I really enjoy getting lost in
these characters in discovering things
about them and feel whether it's because
it's a from a historical period or just
creating some kind of just trying to be
innovative and create something new and
different and still fit the peace and
the character being honest and truth to
it now before you made your living as an
actor what type of odd jobs that you
have well come on jobs today how did you
support yourself mm-hmm you know I I
started gosh I'm a first job I think I
was like twelve wearing at the car my
step dad's car dealership ordered
washing cars and stuff but I wasn't even
acting man i was in school and then uh
and then i started working at a gym in
culver city right before my grandfather
and grandmother lived so that was in the
culver center it was nautilus plus at
the time so i was a trainer and then
moved up to into sales and they offered
a the offer view management job and if
time I was 18 it was like I was real you
know social social little butterfly you
know knowing every
so they're like man you do really good
in sales and I was like wow I you know I
got these auditions and stuff like so
you make me make 60 grand a year and you
know eighteen sixty grand years like a
million bucks i'm like wow sixty was
here but you gotta you got to give it
back you gotta stop auditioning so i
said uh it was tempting but I just I
just couldn't do it you know and I knew
I could make the money so that manager
left and the new manager came on and i
told him i said look man i said i want
to go into sales but i'm not going to
give up acting up one thing I will tell
you I won't work my days off so long as
you let me go on auditions and I had a
small and that manager things Prince
Jones he works at the LA Fitness is now
I had a I'm sorry I had a smaller age at
the time and God I think I went it was
the summer time I think I went like like
five months without an audition so I
went to prison I said Prince me and I
need a day off man I've worked seven
days away for five months you gotta let
me go to the pitcher sucks man yeah yeah
I hear you that's really funny I did it
but you know I paid off me and I have my
auditions and I take off you know
somebody get caught up in the rain or
you know one time I took off on an
audition on one of those days under
changing their their sales rate so I was
like you know I was stuck in the rain I
was gone for like four or five hours but
you know that was a deal we made and I'm
grateful for it you know and it's on so
it sounds like you know the
entertainment business acting is is it's
in your blood lines and even before that
he move for you auditioning where does
this love come from for acting in terms
of how did you get involved doing that
you know I think because I always grew
up around it wasn't like a wasn't like I
uma want to be an actor I'm not you know
it's all blood for me so it's uh it's
something I grew up around you know my
grandfather of Pedro Gonzalez Gonzalez
was like the only known I guess
contestant slash actor to ever one of
Groucho Marx who at the time was you
know considered one of the greater
comedians of that generation so it was
like you know being a contract player
for John Wayne after that
years a mexican american actor who can't
read becoming a contract player in the
50s for one of the biggest stars in
Hollywood at the time you know it's hard
enough to get where today but he can
imagine dealing with racism back then
and stuff like that so for me it was uh
it was something I was always around and
I just didn't know I mean everybody's
really acting I mean whether it's you
need trying to ham it up for your
girlfriend or your lying to the cop or
you know there are all kinds of
different things that we do whether it's
a different style of clothes that you
put on it might not be truly you just
because you're trying to impress her all
kinds of little things that we do but to
consciously do it for character is a
whole different ball game and I'm I was
always a class clown I was always
getting detention or you know but if I
can if I could give a good joke if I get
the whole class left and detention was
worth it because I got a good laugh and
then all the jobs I had people always
say you know hey are you an actor are
you were committing or there so you that
so the signs were always pointed to that
and then my grandfather one day was
complaining about how none of the
grandkids fall in his footsteps and I
felt bad and I never thought I'd be the
one to do it I tried to employ my cousin
my sister and they did they weren't
having it so I thought you know hey I
knew this was something that I wasn't
going to try it was someone's going to
do so certainly I told my grandpa's one
would think about this I thought about
it for about two months and at that time
I was teaching of martial arts to a
bunch of kids I thought martial arts for
quite some time um and it was at that
point I just decided one day you know
I'm gonna do it in the first 30 days I
got taft-hartley oh wow it's amazing
when you make that commitment when you
make that decision how all of a sudden
you know you can you can have which
would you would you dream you can happen
sure and I didn't know what the hell I
was doing I knew how to make people
laugh so I gonna just be a clown and I
didn't know I could change line but I do
it anyway and it changed the commercials
for me you know so I slowly started to
learn just by the reactions on their
faces what worked and what didn't work
and it is um I
does it not actor I learned that it too
you know strike those heart chords make
you feel for characters and that part's
really fun like when you get to do a
character like Capote or when we in the
casting room and you know you get a
casting director like like scissors like
starts crying when she's reading lines
with you like wow like must have read
this thing like 50 times I'm making you
cry like it makes you feel good as an
actor to know that you can touch people
you and that's one of the greatest
choice for me is like whether you love
me passionately or whether you hate me
practically I want to evoke some kind of
emotion in you like I want to matter as
an artist I don't want to be that
forgotten character is that you know and
I don't mind playing small roles in
films I don't I don't mind it at all so
long as i can i can make it go to him
like you know like like a like a rolling
wounds with traction they originally
wanted me to read for the the ian
somerhalder rolling you know he's a
handsome devil at ian's summer like a
little porcelain doll you know and um
and I knew that's what they're looking
for but I read the role of Rupert I
thought I was like I was shooting the
last cows at the time when I read this
it was Roger Roger Avery wrote it who
also wrote pulp fiction's you know so
the dialogue is incredible and I thought
man we replace Rupert who guys got his a
big old donkey balls and ended up being
so I had no intent even going after her
but I was like it kind of scared me a
little bit mm-hmm like it scared me now
pursuing acting is so difficult you know
we have a lot of young actors that they
listen to the show I mean first off it
takes years of honing your craft the
rejection can be unbearable and you
often hear that acting by itself is
actually the easy part compared to
booking the job so in your case not only
were you trying to book the job but
you're you know you're fighting against
Latino stereotypes how did how did you
break through this barrier and and what
kind of effort to take on your part and
what was your mental attitude during
this time well initially you know I mean
I wasn't really funny Latino story
attached at all because a good chunk of
my friends wrong you know gangbangers
from Culver City or 18 street or you
know
a trade gangster crips and you know a
lot of those guys are still good friends
of mine today um you know I got a deer
homeboy from Inglewood was locked up
right now I'm doing his life story hmm
um he's got a beautiful story like
estava over as dear friend of mine he
was just in that whole ride situation
that happened thank God he wasn't
involved with it so in the beginning for
me I'm in fact I was a little upset that
uh you know I could do a film like 187
you know Kevin Reynolds and icon
producing and you know in the samuel l
jackson who was probably one of them is
still one of my greatest mentors and
taught me so much in this business and
to see that somebody like Robert De Niro
could get nominated for portraying a
gangster from from his you know cultural
community but yet my own community the
Latino community would not embrace a
gangster from arts I just didn't see
that double standard like wow so you got
to be Italian to be appreciated playing
gangbangers mmm the enemy so that that
that wasn't really a problem it wasn't
until you know I wanted to start playing
other roles that I realize that they
weren't letting me so that was different
in regards to the rejection now I think
there's you gotta you gotta really think
about why are you doing it do you know
are doing it like for the fame were you
doing it for the glory I think some of
these people that come out here you know
they want like this like this glam like
you know you've got these reality shows
you've got like all these like
non-acting type of things and you know
all due respect they have their
audiences and people love to watch on me
and they're sensational I'm not one of
them personally but for me to go in and
act it's like I'm I'm an entertainer
yeah I'm a fourth-generation entertainer
I love to perform so if you go in to
give a good performance don't give a
good real i call you gave a good read
I'm like oh anybody read a book and you
want to give a girl like you get a
fourth grader to read yeah I want to
give a good performance and that been
studying that means preparing that means
come in do a little bit of the Wardrobe
do some of the makeup you know do some
dialect tweaking you know do some some
word tweak and if you've done the
homework and you've really gone
to it you'll find little loopholes
you'll find little problems I mean these
writers are writing screenplays a lot of
times they're looking for you know
they're looking for that help you know
I've had I've had directors wait for me
to get to set knowing that I was going
to change the dial hug you know because
they couldn't fix it so you know you can
allow yourself to be rejected but that's
to rob yourself of the fruits of giving
a great performance in that room you
know when you go in there you have an
audience I know there's other people
that might disagree they think a real
audience is in the theater but you know
that is my theater you know you can't
tell me in that audition that I don't
have somebody behind a tape recorder I
may be behind the video camera or the
directors not there the Kashmir people
people are watching you and when you're
on set people are watching you so I you
know to get rid of that whole rejection
thing if you love performing go in there
and give a great performance I
don't love it you know have them like
just that feeling of like wow like you
entertained them and they smiled are
they like well we've never seen you see
that look on our faces that's fine
absolutely it almost sounds you know a
lot of people that they're not willing
to put in that that work you know they
did it they don't have that passion that
they're not willing to do you know just
just the stuff that that you're going to
do because you know because you want to
you know you know what I mean it's
either either they don't they don't put
in the work and or they just forget that
it's like you've created this beautiful
child and now you're like neglecting it
because they've got another thing that
they could possibly give you excuse me
they could possibly give you like the
job but it's like you don't know that
might not that job might not be the
right job for you and you don't know you
know what jobs coming next it's like you
know people think actors think the
reputation is you know what they do what
they put in the can was on the rez but
you know I'd love to put some my
auditions on my resume I've gotten jobs
like I've gotten jobs because of
auditions that I'd done like I wasn't
right for this you know a private mple I
went in red for Michael Mann on Miami
Vice killed it slam it Michael man
grabbed me I broke down into tears my
emotional triggers were a little loss I
couldn't quite I couldn't quite get rid
of it all it kept like building and
building and you
grab me and shook means I you did good
son you did great and didn't that smell
like Michael Mann do something like that
that's that's all I need to do y'all
need the job that's my reward right
there that's all so I didn't get that
part but you know alejandro gonzález
from babble you know was shown that
audition and that's how I got the role
in Babel so you don't know you know it's
like it's not the job you don't get
today so job they're gonna consider you
till we exhumed two months you know a
year down the road about keeping that
red polish too sharp you need be you you
want to be a reliable actor you want you
want them to know you know that they can
count on you to come in and bring the
goods now we have a question from actor
james anthony McQuillan he says that you
are known for disappearing in your
characters how do you choose your
projects and are you getting scripts
sent to you all the time I do get
scripts into me but that doesn't mean
anything anybody get scripts in solemn
you know it's like now you get scripts
us like it's like I've got I got friends
like I'm writing script is good it's
almost done when it's done I'm gonna
send it to you I'm like all right so I
mean I was just not finance and you have
a direct or anything uh I mean is there
something you want me to do it down
others there's no role for you and if I
want you to read it oh god sad a sitter
I or II just screaming I got to do
trying to get my own projects there I do
but then sometimes you get good scripts
into you too um it was the other party
that question um let's see he was
working my roles yeah how do you choose
all right you know the rules for me I
like I like to create something and then
they go straight the opposite direction
you know it's it's just I like to you
know you can't uh you know you do you my
production company's culture don't free
you know it's like you do too much of
the same thing and they're going to want
to see that same thing over and over
again so I really like to shake things
up I really like to create different
characters are really enjoy getting lost
and it could be partly you know just a
just a love for doing that it's kind of
a kind of like a magic act
um and then also you know I think I'm
just more comfortable playing of the
people than I am myself there's a
handful of rows me always try to find
things within characters that you could
latch on to you can find one little
thing that you can identify with and you
can build upon that and some characters
are really close to you and then others
you just you just create nuts that's
really fun so I consciously go out and
my management on my team over at R or
later they're consistently going out and
finding things they kind of know they
know what makes me tick so you know
something that's kind of easy or simple
or something I've done before is it's
just I get bored man I just need to be
challenged I love a good challenge and I
love working with great actors there's
great talent attached to it you got
Anthony Hopkins you got you know guys on
that level where I'm just like man I
just I just want to hang out with the
Great's and learn and just just throw
the ball with them you know working with
alan arkin oh and you know sunshine
cleaning and we sat in the makeup
translate well kid what do you think
about this scene I was like miss Alan
Arkin well I'll tell you mr. oh yeah
that's what I think about what do you
think mr. Arkin it's like what's alan
arkin wow good man this is
sweet you know so in that vein
in a minute is it it could be any factor
i mean it is is that the project is the
role is if the the filmmaker the script
the actors what is there one thing in
particular other sites there's no one
thing in the ticket it's a variety of
things you got you know you got all
those elements the director in the
script of the role um you know there's
great Indies out there like the tiger
lands are the one I just did the
experiment with adrien brody and forest
whitaker for that already worked with
and Aging's an old friends so that was a
good time you know so you know I try not
to be a mood
the dollar and I think people kind of
know that that's kind of not my cup of
tea like that I just uh I moved by like
the project never has anything to do
with money no no I know my managers want
to change that do it for the love ya and
that shows do you question yourself ever
as an artist as how so do you doubt
yourself ever sure I think every great
artist does I think every great artist
and every poor artists like you always
gotta wonder like the end that I go too
deep am I too far am i yeah you have to
question I think that's part of the
process though I mean exploration and
questioning and in the doubt though that
doubt can can break you sometimes but uh
you know I try to just I just try to
keep it moving forward it's like you
know it's only gonna hold you back for a
minute I mean you can't I mean how long
you want doubt yourself for how long you
gonna let that way on your shoulders
before you brush it off as here I gotta
keep moving forward let's go let's do it
let's get it done let's do it great you
know how do you go about preparing for a
character you know what is your process
that you know you say you get lost in
these roles you know the firt were the
first ages as you prepare for a
character there's so many different ways
whether you like it could be you know I
love going on youtube I can pick up so
much stuff on youtube and wikipedia and
the internet beans is such a great tool
for that kind of research and then real
life in of itself if you have access to
certain people these these situations or
your characters related to that's always
fun but uh you know sometimes I work on
the outside sometimes I work on the
inside if it's an emotional thing or if
it's a you know I think a perfect
example is uh Mike judges film extract
you know so much for situate is comedy
situational it's not like you're you're
set up and then joke although he's got
those two you know his world is funny
yeah you know and I inicia I just I
didn't want to not be funny to my
judgments I got so much respect and
admiration and love for Hamburg and like
who doesn't right and and so uh I was
really confused and perplexed because I
was overthinking it I was over shooting
it so many times like trying to find the
butter bean boy
joke you know the one to set up and
that's not what it was and then I'm I
was at a premiere and I bumped into
marrying you she said cliff things you
know you pounce on extract I know I just
couldn't you know what more I said I
think honestly I'm overthinking it I'm
overthinking it I watched an episode of
a king of the hill and I thought I
caught I called my managers please I
said if that role is not going yet I
want to get back in there I want to get
back in there I got it I got it I know
what it is and it's just it's just who
he is is just being apart just be you
know what are your current goals and
acting I mean do you feel like you've
given your best performance yeah I'm
always gonna hope for something better I
hope I haven't given my best performance
um you always want to strive for
something more something different or
you know there's so many different
things I still want to get done you know
so you still feel the challenge in front
of you oh yeah most definitely um yeah
it's like you need you take these roles
that are unfamiliar or you know
challenge you want to be emotionally or
physically and and also working with
great actors to working with great
actors just great to be on that page
with them and just to be able to throw
the ball and you know it's kind of like
jamming with a great musician is that
when you're feeling your best when
you're on the set you know with with
these actors and you know is that one of
the best place in the world for you to
be you know honestly it really is I feel
really really alive and I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing
because when I'm at home you know
obviously I'm working on stuff but I
love the whole process i love i love
doing my crew you know it's like
everybody plays apart from the craft
service lady to the the first day da to
the second second to the you know the
guy like there everybody does something
it's like a functioning family and i
love that family use like you're all
working for the common goal of doing a
great you know doing a great film you're
a funny film or whatever it is and to
sit there and do these themes and then
you know when you get to work with
actors are really collaborative and
giving you get to share every now and
then you get your greedy actors your
selfish actors but
most part been fortunate nothing very
blessed to have many mentors and I just
love that I love I love having my crew
go like man MF that seaman if I can rock
me or God that last seen the way you did
like you know when when the dolly guy
comes up like man you know what being a
dolly guy and getting seen it seemed
like you guys just did makes it all
worth wow we need to hear that kind of
stuff on staff to putting in you know 12
14 hour day is like it's a beautiful
thing man that is a beautiful thing I'm
really blessed have you set out in your
career and accomplished everything that
you've wanted to do or is there their
store like a gnawing inside of these are
still more that you want to complete
there's so much more I came I think I'd
need another lifetime uh-huh yeah I mean
I look at people like citizen like like
Orson Welles and all the stuff he did
and how he multitasking I mean his
personal life suffered you know and I
looked at something like John Ford you
know who would work so hard you know
theme of a film that you have a complete
you know break down and go on a drinking
binge and end up either in the hospital
or conducting his next production
meeting from the bed with his whole all
his people in his bedroom you know so
haha you know there's a lot I still want
to get done then I got a couple films
that I want to direct here on the back
burner that are really close um you know
in an honest I'd love to know I'd love
to tackle a great western you know it's
like that's that's kind of like what my
grandpa did he did so many Westerns and
I think it's kind of funny that I
haven't really had a chance to really do
a good Western you know I'd love to just
knock one out like I mean then again are
you gonna find a western like you know
Rio Bravo i think is definitely the top
of my list of westerns i mean there's
some great ones you know the man who
shot Liberty valance and high noon you
got all these these great old westerns
they kind of sit like the the formula
for so many other films that skip that
changed on runs you know um but you know
you got now you got your teen idol
Ricky Nelson sing a song and it you got
D Morton in there and you got the
classic Walter Brennan you know what
birds are there will check to me with
that shotgun I'm a booty get off you
know you got all these crazy wacky
characters you know my grandpa it's like
it's like you know Quentin Tarantino
called it the first buddy picture
because he he actually felt like you
were hanging out with these guys in
prison you know and it's and I think
that's something that so many of these
films missed today is you missed to get
to really learn about some of these
characters you know what cousins a a
police officer and oakley is a sergeant
Chris Craig ways to tap dance with but
he did technical under t he's like
useful if you need to these these fellas
you know stemming you're copying you're
solving crimes and you know taking down
bad guys but you know we're normal
people man we got problems we laugh we
cry we talk we tell jokes there's a
lot of funny fun stuff that happens
while you're cruising around as a cob
to each see that you don't really
see in film or on TV so you know I'm I
may be taking on this a cop role real
soon and I'm planning to bring a bunch
of that fun to it so well just life man
you know you can literally sit on a park
bench you can sit on a bench in front of
starbucks and just watch people just you
don't have to know what they're saying
pick a little piece of dialogue and just
laugh your ass off then we can't care i
love that you love the sittin people
watching well i take the bus oh my god
just just to be amongst it because
there's so many fascinating people you
can could take the but taking the bus is
like 10 magic now it really is but your
dog when I yeah it's it's phenomenal to
take it for Grandma oh my god I'm taking
the bus like yes
fun it's really great camera and then
also it makes you if you're ever down
and you take the bus boy you just change
your attitude once you come off the bus
oh my on their bus there's people
there that I mean yeah they have it so
much Mike you might just need my car
here and take the bus home because I
said ya know Clifton let's say we turn
back the clocks and you had a chance to
start all over as an actor you know yet
you got to keep your current knowledge
you know what would be your plan of
attack Wow keep my current knowledge
that's a real goin brother man that
that's the whole if I would have known
now what I knew there yeah what God you
know what it did something bridges tell
me beau bridges told both me and his
sudden Geordie because you kid just got
a right man when I was younger if we
would have just wrote more we could have
been directing and doing all these other
things so it's stuff that we're all
doing now like you know jordans got some
projects that's getting ready to jump
off he's got a great webisode shall
these developing that's really close to
going and you know I've already shot a
bunch of stuff you know um you know shot
a couple of it try to videos for Zac
Brown who you know was introduced by my
managers at Rorke's they also rep him I
shot two videos previous for the soul of
John black um I got a new video coming
out for him but you know that kind of
stuff is a man I got to tell you I
really love getting behind a camera you
know and I've got great d PSI work with
like you know mark Carter he was
nominated for an Emmy um you know on
Deadliest Catch and then on Brandon
trost who did crank two and halloween
two is coming out soon um but I you know
and these guys got eyes but I just I
love holding a camera I just love seeing
the world through this I you know so
there's just so many and I love you look
at filmmakers you know like forward and
and uh you know Orson Welles and you
think alike you think of these shots of
like you know like the shot in the snow
when the camera is pulling back and it
literally pulls back on this little boy
and something I want like the second
story inside of a building and like how
did
you do that back then I think there's
all these tricks that they did then
today you got cg on it's so easy to just
you know let's just need your master
your coverage but I want to like get
back to that fun like innovative
storytelling you know like that that fun
magic we just get lost and all these
povs and perspectives and you know do
you mind if we plug Wendy Shepherd of
studio matrix though yes I do well Dave
and I are so grateful um when we my girl
yes she's wonderful she's amazing I mean
talk about multitasking she's a hard
worker yeah she's aren't working a good
woman yes she's built your website for
you she has she's done all that stuff
it's it's she's been she's been
hunt me down for a while and I was just
resistant to technology as I think
everybody is um but now she's got me you
know getting into trouble twittering and
stuff and you know but it's good though
it's a good way to connect with the fans
and you know I it's uh it's a great way
to connect to the fans it so it's one
thing my grandpa used to always tell him
he's like you know you know you know you
know you don't really kind of belong to
yourself anyway belong to the people and
the fans without the fans you're nobody
so it's like you know you gotta always
remember the fans so what other kind of
stuff is windy Shepherd help you out
with what Services Association does she
do for you she updates my stuff you know
actually kind of kind of challenge each
other cuz uh you know I'm constantly
thinking myself too so you know she
started the initial stuff and you know
we kind of all throw some ideas at her
and she'll just figure it out you know
so we got some really good stuff going
on the cliff ecology news site where
we've got a great little banner of
different you know one sheets that go by
and click onto it and you see the
trailer for the movie so that it's even
fun for me like oh there's trailer it's
like I'll have to go hunt before I
exactly you know like the new brothers
trailer the Jim Sheridan I love it it's
really powerful and natalie apartment
looks really sexy
we see a sexy and you don't need a
camera to make it look safety she's a
beautiful woman and and that's the thing
you seem to be very keen about now
having it internet presence how
important do you and how important do
you think it is to be visible in on
internet for for young actors and for
filmmakers alright maybe just across the
board I think it's really important me
it's it's the new thing I mean you got
all these magazines and newspapers
folding up and it's all on the internet
now so it's like you kind of like try to
jump on board early on and then I wish I
would have done that sooner but you know
it's like not everybody's ready to make
that change and it's happening you know
when you want it to or not so it is
important we are in studio with actor
producer and director as well I'm
clifton collins jr you can see him
currently in the film extract which open
this weekend you can also see him in the
upcoming films boondock saints two and
the film he just mentioned brothers
which is with tobey maguire and jake
gyllenhaal now deportment as he just
mentioned Sam Sheppard the bad
Sam Sheppard and we also
have another question from filmmaker
Gary King and he writes to us what do
you think of the state of independent
cinema today and the DIY filmmaking
movement ie a tiny crew micro budget etc
I mean that tiny budget micro crew is
how you get your auntie made haha that's
I get most of my video made like I think
sometimes I'm the DP the director and
I'm everybody I've like set up the
camera and just hit record and just done
a scene it's it's important man an
independent filmmaking is like right now
it's it's tough economy and nobody's
really getting paid right now so you
know I when I hadn't aged and I was
talking to myself I know the times are
bad but this is these are the times that
the ground gets incredibly fertile for
independent filmmaking because you don't
have the money for those effects you
don't have you know the money for these
big stars or you know all you have is a
pen and it doesn't cost you nothing to
write you'll write some good dialogue
get smart don't you know
it's just write something good you know
you it doesn't cost nothing to make a
good script you know you get somebody's
heart you don't need an explosion you
get their feelings get their soul make
them move them you know make them get
lost for a wide and that's another thing
about entertaining too is you know you
get to get lost for you know an hour to
you know three hours you know and it's
fun it's it's like it's entertainment
you know all the amazing of directors
directors that you've worked with from
from you know you mentioned Jim shared
and you mentioned JJ Abrams I'm Troy
Duffy might judge you've mentioned
Steven Soderbergh those are just a few
or the filmmakers you work what are some
of the intangible qualities that make
these guys so successful you know the
things that that they share they all
love movies the author of movies in indy
all i have it's funny it's uh look it's
me like JJ he's such a like the original
kids I know my dick and he's such a like
a like this young kid and he's not he's
a man but he sits hernia is so much fun
filmmaking is like we're working 18
hours a day on Star Trek with a nine
hour turnaround so you need to keep the
morale up into you know I'll do anything
for JD he wrote a three-episode arc for
me and alias and he called me one day
and he says then I had heard rumors that
they were kind of circling me and eric
bana for star trek and he said uh
Clifton a solution and I got this they
want to talk about sure JJ what he's
played dumb he was a souther these
characters they're the bad guys they're
kind of like space pirates uh the
Romulans me gave me the whole backstory
and like okay yeah mmhmm yeah you know
what it's it so well you know I want
offer to you and you know what do you
think you want to do it I was like hmm I
don't know JJ gonna come back in like
what
witcha man I'd love working he'd
sit there and be boxed late at night and
you gotta keep like he's like hello oh
yeah did somebody order 30 pizzas like
you start doing like these phone jokes
and stuff is like you know he'll start
beatboxing singing a song you know it's
like this was a set where like at the
end of the week like the producer would
come up to to you know just thank
everybody for for the hard work that
everybody done and and I got to tell you
it there's so much love that surrounds
changing the people that he works works
with like from brian burke EO just
although all the way around data you
know there was people with tears in her
eyes when this window when the when the
producer said this because you knew that
he meant it you know engine sheridan I
mean he's an incredible fun when you
look at his body of work you know the
name of the Father in the boxer and and
Soderbergh is like just a mean he's like
you're having a friend on set when he
shows like yeah I Steve like a I just
want to sit and talk to I want to listen
to him in its it then throw the ball
around you know some of those things you
know like we're drinking the wine table
after I was tortured in traffic is a new
so much of that evolve just out of us
sitting down in having some lunch like
you know what do you think about the
scene today cliff actually no I was
thinking some cool man i know it says
this but you know i'm gonna state of
desperation I think what if I just grab
that bottle of wine man and and you know
like like just friggin chugged it you
know like my class went out the window
you know we just like to literally throw
the ball and it was a it's fun
collaborating with people like that i
love the collaboration you know you
can't i suppose you can make a movie
buddy so but you really can't you know
it's like that's where all the fun is
absolutely you know all these guys you
know all the all the big-name directors
and you know big name you know all the
big-name directors that you work with it
are there any of these guys that don't
know what they're doing does it just
curious oh yeah well you know what I
went out without naming their name
without amazed but this is this is where
my manager starts calling my cell phone
don't say the name
oh yeah which what you have been
surprised um I guess surprised isn't the
word i have a really bad habit of acting
out when I work with a captain of the
ship that pretends that there's no
iceberg in front of Titanic go ahead
it'll be great there's a big tech
there's a big guys break there sir it's
ok we'll be fine it's like those melons
really wow really wow and this is and
with some pretty big name directors only
nicknames that we would know oh yeah
yeah but you know it's those moments
where it's like like damn like I I just
you know it's like everybody looks up to
the captain of the ship to the director
it's like you know an actor wants to be
directed you know you want to have a
anyone ever guy knows what he's doing
and what he's talking about and
knowledgeable and you want to have that
that kind of like that God like father
like big brother figure they return to
who's going to help you in this world
that's been created when they don't have
answers it's disheartening or when they
know you got mutiny on the set or you
know the crew is like you they're all
working for you man they're busting
their asses and you should appreciate
them because you know they're not you
know they're not making a million
dollars you know they're busting their
assets they want to do a great job you
know and I love that love all these
people that work really hard for the
same cause it's a beautiful thing so
with that in mind what do you think the
best thing oh I'm looking to knock or a
director do for an actor that's the best
thing to bring out a good performance
and guide him I mean gosh so many people
would think everybody works differently
I suppose I guess I mean for me
personally I try to find out how how the
director working I adapt really quickly
to any environment and it's something
I've done since I was a child like I'd
hang out my black friends and then
suddenly you know I sound black right
hang out what Mexican friends I sound
Mexican or I could pick up accents
really fast you know it's just something
I've always done so I also pick up you
know how directors work and it was
really funny because I remember working
with Joel Schumacher on Thailand where
you know he'd sit
tuck to every actor for about an hour
you know and just see what you're about
what you've gone through and what you're
going through the time I was breaking
all my girlfriend at the time so when we
had that big scene with the Colin
Farrell in the bathroom where I'm a
whole breakdown I'm he was trying to get
me to this place and you know he used
all these different techniques that
there weren't any of the things that i
was using because i was just working off
the dialogue in it was so close to home
that that i was just kind of going
through this guy's journey but you know
your ex-girlfriends out there
four different guys write me up ready go
I'm like that's really cool job but uh I
told you I broke up with her and I don't
care about her anymore so what do you
want me to do the scene go hey I swear
to God I will cut to a clip of Colin
Farrell every time if you do this thing
like this well call is my friend I liked
it that's pretty nice you Joe what he
want to do the scene buddy Wow but it
was a love working with Joe and we
mailed that scene he just like screamed
he threw his hands I mean yes Brent I
said cuz he said something cuz you're
coming from a place of anger not of
sympathy and I thought were was that
some direction mr. Shue ma che I said
speed roll those cameras let's roll and
that was that then that's actually the
take in the arm and film my love working
with Joe he's so a maternal and I'm just
a funny dude I hope I get to work with
them again and you and you yourself on
set as a director hot you know how do
you begin to work with your actors you
know what have you learned from all
these greats you know I try to figure
out just what's going on in their head
and what they think about this character
and if you know on the same page I mean
so far you know the video world's been
fairly it's just a different it's a
different beast you know you're you're
putting together you know a narrative
sometimes with the performance you know
and sometimes you know there's just so
many there's none up there I know
there's rules I like to break them all
cuz that's when you come up with all the
new creative stuff that you've never
seen before you know when you break the
rules and um and and that's also where
part of the fun lies for me too but this
new ones seriously
balancing act the one that I'm working
on for Jamie so it's just different but
I love where you would actors i love
actors i love creative people whether
you're a musician a dancer you know in
the musicians are all different to it's
like you know collaborating with Zac
Brown is a I can't tell you what a joy
it's like it this man's got no ego and
eats where you had a professional career
since he was a child albeit you've been
playing since he would Johnny started
playing guitar on your six in classical
when he was eight you know his album
just went platinum so last week mom yea
rather buddies yeah so uh the whole band
and he's getting ready to have a its
third child little Georgia so um but you
know you need to get your other artists
or more eccentric so you're just like
how do I get him to do this you know
recently I had one of my my second
camera operators go like can I get a guy
get him to come back over here and stand
by the bus like no you can't in fact
don't even speak to him you catch him
when he's walking don't tell him to do
you got to be ready to just shoot I
have my camera on at all times just to
catch that magic moment when it happens
doesn't mean you're shooting all the
time but you have to be aware of what's
going on like certain guys just exist
and that's who they are you know so
these musicians are not actors you know
there are people that they express
themselves through their music and you
got to be ready to catch their moments
and you know in regards to the narrative
any when you got your story and stuff
that's that's a whole nother thing you
get actors or you know whatever if
they're if the musician wants to be a
part of it to know one of the story too
are you okay watching yourself on film I
know a lot of actors out there they're
real squeamish about seeing themselves
or critical yet known hmm it depends you
know I mean sometimes you're really
close to films you know sometimes you
know certain things in your your lives
were going on you know as so much of my
life I can remember just through the
different movies I was doing like I
watched moving in a little jar memory
I've had like some real heavy things
happening films
and just uh you know it's um um and how
do you watch your film so you know
probably our last question here you know
like d you know how do you prefer to
watch film um you know were you watching
movies these days I like watching movies
at the arclight but uh I washed out of
the past last night Robert Mitchum and
you know so i watch that at home that
that's fun it's like you know I got a
big old you know big giant 52 you know
1080i screen so i get to really go off
and watch i just got real bravo on
blu-ray after we watched out of the past
being one of my buddies in a in a an
acquisitions executive i won't mention
the studio um but uh was over and i said
man let's watch the car chase from
bullet I got it on blu-ray and let's
give a as if that's why you're in
acquisitions and you're not a creative
exec but we were like glued you turn it
up and it's seen as that bad guy buckles
his seatbelt at 68 dodge charger and
that light turns green the tires go like
they just like the start just the car
chases and Susie between in the freaking
68 GT you can just watch that car do you
see I seen that car chased by like 70
times that's a fun chase to watch yeah
but um I think the art lights a good
place it's a little pricey but you know
you get it's quiet nobody's kicking your
seat you've got space and it's really
it's really a great place to take in a
movie and fill your audience and great
sound systems and stuff that's right so
you do likes you you love getting out to
the theater I do mean brother you know
getting back to the you know watch my
performances and stuff it's like you
know extract you know if you had a bunch
of friends in it like to mention my
judge being a great friend and you know
brothers you know brothers was a heavy
one I'd lost three friends you know
Johnny grant the mayor and brad renfro
pass and then Heath Ledger to so like it
was a really emotional time phone was
hard to get to some of those similar
scenes so I think just in just watching
that film will be tough like to
disassociate yourself and you know it's
fun to enjoy the fridge once again those
are the fruits of the labors but you
have that personal stuff happening are
you getting through you can't help but
but like be taken out of it we've been
speaking with actor producer clifton
collins jr why water pleasures been
clifton a have you here in studio and in
the tap into your passion it's just been
such a joy to have you here with us this
morning i really appreciate you guys man
thank you for that really appreciated
you know we want everyone listening to
go and see extract which which is in
theaters right now I'm already hearing
some good buzz about it here buzz about
me getting my ball blown off why I see
something new trailer but if I can loose
ball for America's you were laughter
it's well worth it I go when I can still
win the Tour de France you know and we
were also just upon the fact that
boondock saints two is getting ready for
theaters and the movie brothers which
you've mentioned a couple of times gotta
look out for their nose and any any
other plugs anything we should be aware
of yeah ticket check out the trailer man
check out the trailer with the boondock
saints two it's number one on GN right
now so awesome people are freaking out
over it Troy Duffy is back back in the
saddle again he's gonna be here for a
minute too so get ready folks and and we
can find more on your work clifton
collins jr calm that's correct yo check
out for Betty Jean to the solo John
black it's gonna be hit 90s really soon
I'm really proud of it it's got a lot of
older black exploitation influences and
old Hollywood stuff and the neato
apartment the landmark from Sunset
Boulevard so a progressive left-handed
blues player John black some all right
all right his albums on itunes also
we're gonna look into that as well very
nice please join us again next Sunday on
la talk radio's film courage have a
great week